>>> LET'S FACE, HAVE YOU A BIG
ROACH PROBLEM, YOU'VE TRIED
EVERYTHING, AND SPRAYED HARMFUL
CHEMICALS, BUT NOTHING SEEMS TO
WORK UNTIL NOW.
HI, MY NAME IS NED, I'LL GET RID
OF YOUR NASTY ROACH PROBLEM FAST
AND EASY, WITH MY ALL NEW NED'S
ROACH AWAY.
AT NED'S WE KNOW THE ONLY THING
THAT CAN STOP A BAD ROACH IS A
GOOD ROACH WITH A GUN.
THAT'S WHY I SPENT YEARS
PERSONALLY TRAINING AN ARMY OF
MY OWN GOOD ROACHES TO CARRY AND
OPERATE TINY AR-15 RIFLES TO
PROTECT YOUR HOME.
FOR JUST $59.95, MY ROACHES WILL
PATROL YOUR CABINETS, THE STOVE
AND WHEREVER THOSE ROACHES LIKE
TO HIDES.
THE BANG MEANS IT'S WORKING.
SO FORGET ABOUT THOSE SPRAYS.
ROACHES JUST DRINK THAT STUFF UP
LIKE TEQUILA.
YOU MIGHT AS WELL PUT IT IN A
PIÑATA, AND THROW THOSE ROACHES
A PARTY, BUT WITH NED'S ROACH
AWAY, THE PARTY IS OVER.
NOW, SOME PEOPLE MIGHT SAY, BUT
NED, WOULDN'T GUN CARRYING
ROACHES 1YU69 ADD TO MY PROBLEM?
THAT'S SO DUMB IT MAKES ME MAD.
MY ASSISTANTS MAKE SURE ONLY THE
BEST HIGH CHARACTER, GOD FEARING
ROACHES CAN CARRY GUNS.
>> IT'S TIME TO GO TO CHURCH.
AND NONE OF MY ROACHES ARE GAY,
AND FOR REALLY BAD PROBLEMS, YOU
NEED NED'S ROACH AWAY MAX, WITH
BUMP STOCK.
PLUS MY ROACHES ARE TRAINED TO
TEACH THEIR BABIES HOW TO SHOOT,
CREATING A CYCLE.
SO THERE'LL BE GUN CARE ROACHES
IN YOUR HOME FOR GOOD.
SO GET NED'S ROACH AWAY SYSTEM
TODAY.
YOU DON'T NEED PEST CONTROL, YOU
NEED PEST SOLUTIONS.
LADY, YOUR HOUSE IS NASTY.
>> SORRY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]